las vegas aviators return to the diamond
three weeks from today finally
opening night it is set for thursday may
6. but to make that happen they need
workers there
bianca holman is there this morning i
should say at the las vegas ballpark
with details on a job fair this weekend
well if you love the aviators now's your
chance where you can work right here
in the team store you can help fans find
their favorite merchandise to wear
when there is the first game so we've
got the hats we've got the mask
i think there's probably even some
things in here for your pup but to tell
us more about
the season coming up and i'm joined here
by chuck johnson the gm so baseball
there's going to be a first pitch soon
right on yeah may 6th about 600 days
between our last aviator game and the
one on may 6 so
super excited for opening day yeah and i
know you all have been busy you have
hosted blood drives again to help
with uh you know fight the coveted
pandemic and getting those platelets and
things like that
so you actually need staff for so many
different positions yeah now with the
60 home games we need that staffed out
it takes a few hundred people each game
so we're going to be hiring for about
100 positions here saturday from 11 to
3.
all right tell us all we've got the team
store where else will folks be working
yeah you know you can come in and get a
job here in the retail store
our cleaning crew we will have our game
day
event staff fan experience fan guest
services
parking attendants valet parking traffic
control
and you know we have a swimming pool out
here bianca so we need a couple
lifeguards as well
all right so from lifeguard security you
all got you guys got it all so again
this is happening saturday right give us
the details one more time
so you got time to repair you guys yeah
saturday uh right here at the ballpark
enter through the main
gates uh make sure you bring your resume
uh interviews will be done
that day from 11 to 3 o'clock uh hiring
managers will be here and
all of our contractor vendors will be
out here hiring all right perfect
here to answer those questions for you
so again all this information will be
listed on our website i'm going to send
it back to you guys in the studio
how fun i can't wait to get back out
there john through the ballpark i know
well i'm thinking about it getting a job
out there
think of all the hot dogs you can eat
just crush hot dogs non-stop
i think sherry's already claimed that
job yeah well i could always change you
know i mean i could change up my pitch a
little bit
some nachos get your peanuts
i think i can do that